bonsoir et bienvenue dans le set vite
sport l'émission dédiée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite à le sommaire de votre émission
football château qui évolue en dhr s'est
incliné comme l'année dernière au 6e
tour de la coupe de france les yvelinois
ont été éliminés par une cfa
viry-châtillon score final 1 but à 0
pour les essonniens les détails dans
cette édition apnée l'élan courtois
xavier delpy a terminé à la troisième
place des championnats du monde en
italie sur l'épreuve du jazz blue le but
est de parcourir la plus grande distance
en profondeur de 10 mètres nous le
recevrons sur ce plateau dans quelques
minutes
en bas les féminines de montillot
bretonnants concert deuxième défaite en
deux matches de national
elles ont perdu 32 à 24 dans leur
gymnase le résumé de la rencontre est à
suivre dans ce magazine et peut enfin
l'émission tour d'horizon des principaux
réseaux les principaux rendez vous
sportif et résultats sportifs du
week-end un département nous parlons
notamment du skipper versailles tanguy
de lamotte qui a pris le départ de la
transat jacques vabre
il n'y a pas eu de miracle au stade de
finale terry de chatou les cathos vient
qui évolue en dhr se sont inclinés comme
l'année dernière au 6e tour de la coupe
de france
ils ont été éliminés par une cfa
viry-châtillon score final 1 but à 0
pour les essonniens les images sont
signés elodie moines
l'exploit était si proche les rouges de
chatou qui évolue en dhr se sont fait
sortir dans le stade au 6e tour de la
coupe de france par viry-châtillon une
équipe de cfa héroïque les et bin-houin
qui ont terminé la rencontre à dix après
un carton rouge on a réussi à tenir en
échec leurs adversaires les essonniens
ont finalement réussi à marquer en fin
de match soit en finale 1-0
on était bien en place eux aussi après
on a la chance d'avoir des joueurs qui
ont également joué à un niveau plus
élevé aussi donc avec une certaine
expérience aussi dans dans l'aspect du
jeu comment gérer certaines situations
et dans ces matches et là j'ai vraiment
serré ça se joue à 40 quasiment à celui
qui marque le premier ouais je pense
qu'il nous a manqué un peu de de
condition physique en deuxième mi temps
on a qu'on a un peu baissé de pied je
trouve qu'on a fait une très bonne
première mi temps on a laissé un petit
peu de de force
du coup forcément vendéen mi temps
c'était peut-être un peu plus difficile
et voilà ça s'est joué sur un sur un
coup de pied arrêté sur un détail ce que
j'allais en vidéo avant le match mais on
va se passer comme ça après avoir
éliminé rueil malmaison et soisy
l'épopée des cas tout vient s'arrête
comme l'année dernière au 6e tour on a
fait un beau parcours on s'arrête au
même tour que l'année dernière mais on a
joué une cfa c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on voulait aussi sortir contre une
contre une grosse équipe et voilà qu'on
n'a pas on n'a pas à rougir de notre
défaite et ça va nous permettre de
continuer pour la suite et puis je pense
qu'on peut quand même dire qu'on sortait
hôte de la coupe de france avec un un
bon match contre une belle équipe en
face aux six mois après cette aventure
en coupe de france ce château de voir
plonger dès ce dimanche dans le
quotidien du championnat de dhr et
qu'elle vient sont pour l'instant 2e du
classement après quatre journées on
passe maintenant aux autres résultats de
ce 6e tour de la coupe de france trois
représentants des yvelines se sont
qualifiés pour le prochain tour
versailles a remporté une victoire sur
la fin contre grigny grâce à une
réalisation signée de bouyer à la 78e
minute 1 0
de son côté la cfa de poissy est allé
s'imposer facilement l'extérieur sur le
terrain d'angers 1 sur le score de 4
buts à 1 mantes a également racheté sa
qualification à l'extérieur sur le
terrain de 1000 sur marne 1 0 du côté
des déceptions en plus de l'illumination
du château où se fait sortir 1-0 sur son
terrain contre l'entente sannois saint
gratien
il y aura donc trois représentants
yvelinois pour le prochain tour après le
football nous allons parler des
championnats du monde d'apnée avec notre
invité à examiner le petit élan courtois
xavier delpy a réalisé une belle
performance en apnée il a remporté la
médaille de bronze aux championnats du
monde d'apnée masse qui se sont déroulés
du 5 au 10 octobre en italie à ischia
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir xavier
delpy sur ce plateau bonsoir vous avez
remporté donc votre médaille dans la
catégorie blues jazz blue est ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter cette épreuve
alors il faut savoir qu'on appelait
effectuant plusieurs disciplines un
petit peu comme un athlétisme très
brièvement des épreuves essentiellement
en piscine soit deux longueurs tir
maximum de distance parcourue avec ou
sans palmes le temps n'importe pas parce
que ce soit une question qu'on me pose
des épreuves de statique ou là c'est le
temps maximum passer sous l'eau puis dix
épreuves en mer monde est sens le plus
profond paix possible également avec ou
sans palmes et puis une épreuve un petit
peu hybride mais que j'adore mois
particulièrement qui est donc le jump
blues
elles sont effectivement exactement qui
va bien ma physiologie donc on descend à
10 mètres de profondeur
et puis on va faire le maximum de
distance autour d'un carré qui fait
quinze mètres de côté
et quelles sont les qualités pour
exceller dans cette discipline on doit
alors les qualités qu'on doit voir on
pense souvent que l'entraînement en
apnée c'est se mettre en liga et puis
rester sans respirer pendant des heures
c'est en fait un sport extrêmement
complet c'est pour ça que je suis tombé
dedans c'est aussi le médecin qui s'y
intéressent énormément on a toute la
préparation habituelle dans n'importe
quel sport l'entraînement cardio la
préparation physique du gainage de la
technique spécifique de nage et notre
entraînement physique spécifique en
apnée que ce soit en dynamique en
statique l'adaptation pulmonaire à la
profondeur de l'adaptation thoracique
pour prendre le maximum d'air et avoir
un réservoir le plus rempli possible
c'est extrêmement complet et le côté
mental et en plus extrêmement crucial et
est ce que vous vous attendiez a gagné
7,7 médaille de bronze au championnat du
monde alors donc il ya trois ans moi
j'avais eu l'immense honneur et
privilège de gagner le championnat
d'europe
ex-aequo avec l'italien d'impliquer les
gorgonzola avec le record du monde
là je suis chirurgien que j'ai eu ces
dernières années très très très occupé
la piscine de maurepas augementerait un
règlement qui avaient fermé ces cinq
derniers mois
donc la palette est difficile mais voilà
c'était un retour en compétition
internationale en fédération et je suis
très très contente de cette troisième
place d'autant que la première place a
été prise par mon ami arthur gaborit
avec le record du monde qui reste
français et vous aviez le record du
monde c'est sa voix la star je lui donne
quand même avec plaisir mais j'ai
réalisé qu'on dit on ne reprend dans 185
mètres un record à 785 m et du coup le
nouveau record qui était donc battu
justement par le français arthur guérin
boeri il l'a porté à malo 62 cents à m
c'est une performance qui est difficile
à atteindre
où
vous pouvez l'atteindre peut-être dans
le futur alors j'espère pouvoir cette
année m'entraîner dans des bonnes
conditions et j'espère bien pour aller
le chercher c'est mon intention c'est
jouable ou c'est un record vraiment
inhumain que personne n'était l'apnée
progresse énormément tous les ans
découvre énormément de choses qu'on a
dites choses différentes à travailler
par rapport à d'autres sports
donc on a une marge de progression qui
est toujours étonnante nos performances
ont doublé en 20 ans toutes les toutes
les disciplines
donc oui c'est énorme ça paraît
incroyable mais je pense que c'est comme
si un jour vous de raisonnable c'est une
de mes envies que c'est une épreuve que
j'aime particulièrement
donc la compétition s'est déroulée dans
un contexte un peu particulier un mois
après l'accident
guillaume néry donc je le rappelle
guillaume néry a été victime donc d'une
erreur de des juges le niçois est fait
une syncope suite à cette erreur
les juges avaient avaient mal mettrai en
fait le la distance si je me trompe pas
est-ce que vous quand vous avez commencé
la compétition est ce que vous y avez
pensé à cet accident
et est ce que vous êtes dit finalement
ça me fait peut-être un petit peu peur
de de continuer alors plusieurs choses
la première c'est qu'on a pu mais moi je
suis chirurgien je veux absolument
maîtriser tout ce qui m'arrive et tout
ce qui se passe autant pour moi que pour
mes patients
il aurait été inconcevable commencé
l'année sans me sentir parfaitement en
sécurité
il faut savoir qu'à chaque entraînement
on se surveille des uns les autres à un
ou deux mètres près c'est un sport qui
maintenant contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser extrêmement sécurisé d'autre part
en arrivant sur les championnats on a vu
que même si tu es les premiers
championnats profondeur que ma
fédération officielle internationale
il était extrêmement préparer les moyens
de sécurité était vraiment important
bien d'autres dispositions notamment des
plongeurs en scooter qui venait jusqu'à
une profondeur de 50 mètres
un retour vidéo sur la plate forme de
fonds et comme vous avez pu voir ou à
l'image donc voilà sécurité vraiment
assurer à chaque instant d'autant que
c'est contrairement à ce que les gens
habituellement peuvent penser l'endroit
le plus critique pour nous dans une
plongée n'est pas le plus profond c'est
au contraire proche de la sortie l'apnée
ou même une fois qu'on est sorti le
temps que le sens serait oxygène donc on
a cet intérêt de 20 à 30 secondes qui
peu critique et guillaume a été le
premier à dire que le considérait pas
comme un accident mais comme un incident
s'est jamais sentie vraiment en danger
il a été on porte une longe le ans du
cadre c'est toujours un oeil un système
de contrepoids qui peut nous remonter à
tout moment et la sécurité étaient là
pour faire son travail
après un petit check up il a été
rapidement gagné 1 sur pied il a
replongé ya pas très longtemps à nice
ton coeur et cet accident de guillaume
guéraud et néry à chypre est-ce que
c'est rare ici ou est-ce que ça ce
procès se produit
régulièrement enfin est-ce que c'est
réussi alors oui c'est très rare
l'erreur a étonné beaucoup beaucoup de
gens autant que juge organisateurs et
apnéistes il faut pas oublier qu'on est
un sport jeune et donc tout ça va aussi
aider à faire évoluer les moyens on
n'est pas encore un sport et des budgets
de deux clubs de football les moyens
techniques pour assurer encore mieux la
sécurité puis dès là c'était en
l'occurrence un petit marquage au scotch
qui est qu'on a préférés avec un
marquage la peinture moins sujet à se
décaler ou son bleu et est ce que ce
type d'accident vous fait peur vous et
vous êtes découragé pour poursuivre
alors carrière personnellement non
absolument pas mais c'est vrai que je
doit rassurer mon entourage qui a pensé
normalement comme cambodgienne et est-ce
que vous fixer les limites non c'est ce
pas alors les limites que je me fixe
sont celles que mon corps va me donner
c'est à dire que
va cultiver en apnée vraiment un
équilibre avec soi même on sait que si
on est trop souvent proches de la limite
au bout d'un moment on va plus faire
plaisir on va plus progresser et c'est
de toi sont contreproductifs la
meilleure sécurité c'est de garder une
toute petite marge de sécurité et
découvrir après on a il ya trente ans on
pensait plongé en dessous de 50 mètres
était était impossible pour le corps
humain et puis maintenant voilà on
atteint des profondeurs en poids
constant de plus de 120 m on en apprend
tous les jours on note même si ça
extraordinaire
merci à vous xavier merci à vous
déplacer sur ce plateau encore
félicitations pour votre médaille de
bronze
et on vous souhaite de récupérer votre
corps dans les prochains mois merci
beaucoup on passe maintenant au handball
lourde défaite pour
montigny-le-bretonneux nationale une
féminine lésigny monteyne ceux ci ont
été corrigés 32 à 24 à domicile par
rochechouart lors de la 5e journée du
championnat et saint quentinois ce
concède une deuxième défaite consécutive
le montage est signée à romao est fini
deuxième défaite en deux matches de
national
une pour montigny le bretonneux privé de
quelques cadres lésigny montrent elles
n'ont jamais réussi à contenir les
assauts de rochechouart l'une des
meilleures équipes de la coupe dans leur
gymnase
le score est sans appel 32 24 on n'était
pas loin on revient et puis après on
relâche sur les dernières minutes on
fait des erreurs qu'on ne devrait pas
faire et donc ça coûte cher sur des
équipes du
aux tables on a eu un départ de match
difficile ce qui nous a mis dedans
presque tout le match bon on a su
relever la tête à densifier notre
défense qui nous a permis à près de
récupérer des balles et puis les
les amener jusqu en attaque mais oui il
ya un écart c'est sûr mais pas tant que
ça je pense pas pas donc ça on est loin
parce qu'il ya moins 8 à la fin mai
il faut retenir les bonnes choses et à
son jeu elles ont su relever la tête et
ça c'est ça c'est bien pourquoi pour
l'avenir promu cette année en nationale
une montille retenues visent le maintien
cette saison
après un départ en boulet de canon avec
deux victoires en trois matchs les ig
monteyne marque le pas depuis début
octobre et illinoise reste sur trois
défaites consécutives toutes
compétitions confondues
on va y arriver on travaille beaucoup la
semaine
après je pense qu'il faut vraiment me
garder positif sur chaque match même
s'il va y avoir beau sans doute beaucoup
des fêtes et je pense qu'on va y arriver
il faut rester bien régulière pour rêver
du maintien il faudra engranger le plus
de points possible prochain match
nationale une pour montigny le
bretonneux samedi prochain à 20h contre
pessac et en gironde
les équipes de volleyball de plaisir et
de villes pro ont fusionné en 2000 à
aujourd'hui l'équipe i considère comme
l'une des plus performants du
département pour décrypter cette
réussite nous recevons sur ce plateau
mathieu en frais joueurs de l'équipe 2
masculine et françois omnes responsable
de la section loisirs de plaisir
villepreux bonsoir mathieu qu'est ce qui
fait la force de ce club du puy ya
plusieurs années je pense que c'est un
club qui est très familiale en fait
puisqu'on on a quand même une une équipe
qui dirige le club depuis très longtemps
on assure on essaie en tout cas
d'assurer une certaine continuité
et on a vraiment un coeur très très fort
qui permet de fédérer les gens qui sont
autour de nous françois est ce que ce
club vous met dans les meilleures
conditions pour réussir
oui je pense parce que pour nous ce qui
concerne les loisirs on a quand même la
possibilité de jouer deux séances par
semaine on a l'appui des compétitions
qui viennent nous conseiller sur des
aspects un petit peu plus technique
aussi bien sûr de l'apprentissage du jeu
que sur des aspects très individuelle de
technique
qui sont quand même assez important en
matière de voler donc oui pour nous ça
on a eu un bon encadrement et ça se voit
aussi dans les résultats qu'on a en
compétition loisir au département donc
ya pas d excuse pour or quand on perd
des matches à plaisir les poches
oui on peut dire ça l'équipe masculine
mathieu l'équipe masculine et est
actuellement la sixième place du
classement de prénationale avec 7 points
est ce que la montée est envisageable
cette année oui je pense qu'elle est
tout à fait envisageable ils ont fait
donc là quelques quelques erreurs de
parcours mais c'est surtout dû à des à
des absences on est quand même une
équipe non professionnels donc on peut
avoir quelques absences
maintenant je pense que c'est un groupe
qui a peu évolué depuis l'année dernière
donc c'est déjà un groupe qui est assez
constitué qui est très fort et qui peut
fortement envisagé de tenter la montée
en tout cas où il était prêt à aller à
monter d'un échelon tandis que le groupe
a l'habitude le le groupe peut le monte
maintenant la façon de monter étant très
difficile je pense que ce sera quand
même compliqué pour eux mais je l'espère
en tout cas
et comment expliquez vous cette cette
bonne dynamique il ya trois équipes au
niveau senior du coup a plaisir à
villepreux il ya trois équipes
est ce qu'il ya une certaine émulation
entre entre chaque joueur de l'équipe
les joueurs de l'équipe une de l'équipe
de l'équipe 3 du coup ça forme un noyau
dur et qui fait là aussi duclos
finalement en fait on a on essaie de
faire des passerelles entre les équipes
pour que les gens aient une certaine
émulation et une certaine compétition
entre eux et que au fur à mesure du
temps les joueurs s'ils en ont envie
aussi de passer dans une équipe
supérieure ont fait notamment venir les
jeunes dans l'équipe iii pour qu'ils
commencent à se former avec les seniors
et quand ils sont un peu plus forts on
peut les faire monter en équipe de voir
en équipe une s'ils sont encore
suffisamment forts pour ça donc on
essaie en tout cas de de faire jouer des
équipes ensemble les équipes une et deux
par exemple s'entraînent ensemble le
jeudi comme ça ça permet de jeu de jouer
ensemble voire de faire des oppositions
de temps en temps on a en début d'année
aussi par exemple
un tournoi de préparation et même un
week end d'intégration où les équipes
seniors peuvent se retrouver que ce soit
masculine et féminine ensemble lors d'un
week-end pour pouvoir justement se
fédérer l'ensemble françois les filles
elles sont quand à l avant dernière de
prénationale comment expliquez vous ce
résultat est ce que c'est une mauvaise
dynamique où est ce que vous le sentiez
venir ou non c'est pas qu'on le sent
venir mais l'équipe a quand même connu
l'année dernière une année très
difficile notamment avec la perte d'un
coach
avec le décès d'un coach en cours
d'année donc une nouvelle organisation
des nouvelles joueuses
on est encore qu'au début de la saison
il faut que la mayonnaise prenne
et c'est quand même une équipe qui a un
sur les dernières années eu de très très
beaux résultats
donc on peut leur faire confiance ils
vont sûrement remonter la pente
et là encore avec l'émulation qu'il ya
avec la deuxième équipe féminine
logiquement elle devrait se positionner
mieux dans la dans la poule dans le dans
le courant de l'année
mathieu vous êtes d'accord avec françois
à le voir monter les filles oui je pense
que c'est tout à fait envisageable
sachant que mon comme l'a dit françois
on a eu un nouveau coach et cette année
et il a quand même un projet de monter
une équipe et d'essayer elle aussi de la
faire monter au niveau national dans les
prochaines années nous avons appris à
présent parler de l'équipe de france
vous le savez les blues ont été sacrés
champions d'europe en battant en finale
la slovénie 3 sets à 0
est ce que cette performance mathieu
corner plus de licenciés dans les
yvelines en particulier dans votre club
ben je pense que ça pourrait le faire
maintenant c'est un petit peu enfin
c'est toujours un peu étourdi c'est un
peu tôt même si la france y ont gagné
comme la ligue mondiale au mois de juin
on en a parlé un petit peu mais pas
énormément ça nous a peut-être amené
quelques licenciés mais vraiment pas
beaucoup
là j'espère que la ligue mondiale enfin
le la coupe d'europe au temps pour moi
va permettre d'amener d'autres licenciés
mais je pense qu'il est encore trop tôt
sachant que là en plus c'est les
vacances scolaires donc j'espère c'est
tout ce que je peux dire vous espérez
vous aussi france ah oui on peut
l'espérer
maintenant je pense que pour qu'il y ait
un vrai éclairage médiatique sur le sur
le volet il faudrait que l'équipe de
france se qualifie aux jeux olympiques
de rio est calé figure de façon
honorable de telle façon que
on puisse avoir une exposition
médiatique suffisante pour éveiller la
curiosité des gens bon cela dit moi pour
ce qui est des loisirs on a quand même
une dizaine de jeunes de nouveaux
joueurs tous les ans qui viennent
essayer le volet et va forcément
compétition ou en loisir il ya des
jeunes qui viennent ya des jeunes et des
moins jeunes parce que j'ai quelques
quarantenaire qui s'essaye aussi
aux loisirs aux volets donc non il ya il
y aurait il pourrait sûrement y avoir
une certaine émulation autour du volet
il faut simplement que l'équipe de
france à l'instar d'autres équipes comme
le handball puisse puisse avoir un
résultat vraiment extraordinaire au
moment des jeux olympiques
et là je pense qu'on pourrait
effectivement avoir un petit peu plus de
vocations y compris chez les jeunes
et est-ce qu'il ya des jeunes et des
moins jeunes qui sont venus vous voir en
vous disant je veux être comme ces jours
là l'équipe de france je veux m'inscrire
dans ce club pour être comme eux est ce
que des jeunes qui sont venus voir ou
démangeaisons ou voir en vous disant ça
alors pour être parfaitement honnête non
non ça c'est pas encore arrivé j'attends
avec impatience que ça arrive mais en
l'occurrence ce n'est pas encore arrivé
est-ce que vous par exemple mathieu est
ce que bout à l'entraînement à ce qui
est des gestes que vous essayer de
reproduire un petit peu comme eux là je
pense notamment geste de erin m gap est
justement en finale soit sur le dernier
sur le dernier point sur la balle de
match
est-ce que vous je sais pas ça vous
inspire ça vous donnera envie de
reproduire siges non pas du tout le
dernier geste pas du tout pas du tout là
c'était vraiment très très osées comme
comme geste je n'aurais jamais essayé
surtout sur une balle de match parce que
c'était quand même un score très très
tendue ils ont gagné de très très peu
7la donc moi j'aurais pas essayer
maintenant il ya d'autres gestes on a vu
des gestes notamment en terme de défense
en termes d' attaques qui peuvent vous
inspirera qui sont plutôt eux à terme
d'inspiration je pense notamment au
pointu antonin rouzier qui était
extraordinaire sur ce jour-là ngapeth
fait beaucoup de spectacles mais en
termes de stabilité c'est plutôt
quelqu'un comme antonin rouzier le
pointu qui apporte beaucoup à cette
équipe
et est ce que vous pensez que le volet
du coup on en parlait tout à l'heure est
ce que le volet peut arriver au niveau
du basket ou du handball en france avec
l'équipe actuelle inquiète actuelle je
pense oui c'est une des meilleures
équipes qu'on ait vu dans le volley ball
depuis au moins 20 ans je pense que
on est sur une équipe qui si on même si
on a quelques blessés
ils ont un banc qui est extraordinaire
aussi donc non on a un très bon groupe
c'est un groupe qui je pense si il a les
moyens de gagner le tournoi de
qualification à berlin au mois de
janvier et arrive aux jeux olympiques
fera des très grandes choses et voir
même je l'espère en tout cas
arrivée très haut en tout cas c'est un
bon rayonnement pour votre sport dans
les yvelines en particulier moi et tout
à fait mais je pense que c'est aussi un
un bon exemple et à bonn un bon
encouragement pour que y compris dans le
monde scolaire par exemple on continue à
enseigner le volet au même titre que
d'autres d'autres disciplines
parce que c'est aussi comme ça qu'on va
réussir à détecter les les futurs
rouzier ou les futurs engadget pour les
équipes repas pour rio deux ou trois
coups après merci à vous en tout cas
d'être passé sur ce plateau bon courage
pour la suite du championnat
donc vous êtes de monter cette année
évidemment pour approcher les masculine
j'ai mal à l'équipe masculine
on passe maintenant aux autres résultats
du week end
on commence cette page résultats par du
handball masculin le che n'y arrive
toujours pas promu cette saison en
nationale 2 les chalaisiens ont concédé
une nouvelle défaite à domicile contre
survie sur loire 34 à 30 depuis de la
saison les événements perdu quatre
matchs et ont réussi à accrocher
seulement un match nul mais entame très
compliqué pour une équipe qui vise le
maintien on écoute le coach énéliste
horberg était au micro à d'elodie mort
en ce début d'année ce qui ne fonctionne
pas c'est pas que ça ne fonctionne pas
c'est surtout
l'appréhension est là l'apprentissage du
niveau de nationale 2 qui a pris du
temps à se mettre en place
aussi avec l'arrivée de cinq nouveaux
joueurs donc la mayonnaise a un petit
peu de mal à prendre
donc on est en danger constante
progression en ce moment on continue à
travailler
le médecin toujours dans les têtes on
on n'est qu'au début de la saison on va
pas baisser les bras après ce match là
il nous reste une trêve de deux semaines
pour pouvoir récupérer et les blessés et
continuer à travailler
donc ce qui nous permettra par la suite
de pouvoir
on reprendre le 14 novembre dans de
bonnes conditions
on prend le large à présent avec le
navigateur disait-il coeur tanguy de
lamotte
ce dimanche le versailles de 37 ans a
pris le thé le départ de la 12e transat
jacques vabre avec sakho qui perd son
mandat davis une compétition aussi
appelée route du café qui relie le havre
à ita jay au brésil son objectif est de
terminer la course en moins de dix-huit
jours à 16h l'illinois a été tué à la
15e place dans la catégorie imoca sur
vingt participants la course est dominé
par le voilier monocoque d'alex thomson
et guillermo altadill deuxième le
deuxième versailles est engagé dans la
compétition éric bellion pointe lui à la
17e place des imoca on passe au cyclisme
at carte du tour de france vient d'être
dévoilée par les organisateurs le
parcours au long de 3500 19 km passera
par le mont ventoux avec un départ du
mont saint michel le 2 juillet ce sera
le premier grand départ au nord de paris
depuis 1984 la course proposera quatre
arrivées au sommet deux contre la montre
vous l'aurez compris le parcours ne
passera donc pas par les yvelines cette
année mis des yvelinois devrait être au
départ de la plus grande compétition
cycliste au monde
le versailles et kévin réza pourrait
notamment s'élancer avec le maillot de
la fdj et sur le dos un mot de boxe à
présent rachid achoui un boxeur licencié
au bc de saint quentin en yvelines a
remporté la finale du critérium national
des poids moyens le sportif coachée par
la team farrugia que nous avions reçu la
semaine dernière sur le plateau du 7-8
sport a battu dominique souloy au point
d' à saint-vaast-la-hougue la plus
grande victoire de sa carrière la date
de son prochain combat n'a pas encore
été communiquée on referme ce magazine
par un rendez-vous en football le
chénier troisième du championnat
excellence on reçoit au stade michaud
maurepas dernier du classement avec un
match en moins la rencontre paraît
déséquilibrée sur le papier mais
maurepas est capable de réaliser un
exploit à tout moment on l'a vu avec sa
victoire contre torcy en coupe de france
la rencontre est programmée ce dimanche
à 15 heures
c'est la fin de cette fuite sport merci
d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve jeudi
prochain pour votre nouveau rendez-vous
si on parlait sport nous parlons
notamment du skipper versailles tanguy
de lamotte et de ligne montrent un
françois pervis très belle serait sur tv
fil 78